here with the reaction author of the
bestseller for such a time as this as
insane as it is outnumbered co-host
kaylee mcani along with america first
legal founder uh stephen miller kaylee
we'll start with you tonight okay the
the reality is barry weiss's comments
were dead on accurate
whether it's the wuhan lab the origins
of coronavirus i can add to that all
things donald trump uh the laptop from
hell hunter biden's business dealings
with foreign countries if the last name
was trump would be different coverage
oh no doubt about it and when she
elucidated that the covet lab leak
theory was covered up by cnn brian
stelter went on to say wait wait who
said that well i have the receipts right
here it was in fact crystal is on cnn
who wrote anthony fauci just crushed
donald trump's theory to the origins of
the coronavirus npr said it was debunked
washington post fact checker went on to
say
it too was false now all of a sudden
fast forward washington post says how
the covid lab leak theory suddenly
became credible it was always credible
it just was incredible in the eyes of
cnn because president donald j trump
said it who has been totally vindicated
by the lies of the mainstream media now
exposed yeah where are those where are
those you know statistics that fake news
cnn and msdnc ran uh in terms of covert
people contracting the virus or dying
from the virus in 2020 more people died
this year stephen miller
yeah that's another great point of the
world turned upside down when president
trump was in office and we were struck
by a novel as in brand new pathogen from
china he moved heaven and earth to fight
that virus
he handed joe biden vaccines
therapeutics supply chains mass
everything you could ever need hospital
supplies whatever you could ever
possibly use and more people died under
joe biden so what's gone the death count
is gone
the case count is gone all of the cova
trackers are gone because joe biden's in
office now and apparently that doesn't
matter anymore
apparently not so the the reality is as
joe biden was in the candidate
protection program hiding in his base
basement all throughout the campaign now
i'd argue the only difference kaylee is
this is the presidential protection
program because if it was
donald trump's son that did business
with ukraine kazakhstan china and russia
and donald trump gave putin a waiver and
said nothing with a hypersonic weapon
that can apparently uh be
unleash nuclear weapons around the world
and say nothing um i i think there'd be
a little different reaction humpty
dumpty would be very upset he'd sit on a
wall and have a big fall
oh but don't worry jin saki has told
humpty dumpty that this is the most most
ethical administration in history so
that's all that he needs to know is that
he's carrying the weight of the
propagandist media on the part of the
press secretary but look my former
colleague stephen miller said it best he
said look no president has been handed a
better set of cards he was derided on
media for saying that but he's exactly
right he was given a vaccine
therapeutics a booming economy no
inflation he squandered it because we
elected a candidate from the basement
who you're exactly right now hides in
the executive residence of the white
house last 20 seconds stephen miller
well let me return the compliment and
say that kaylee has been exactly right
from the beginning too this president as
kaylee has repeatedly pointed out has
created every crisis we have and the
media refuses outside of your show in
this network to point out every crisis
we're living through joe biden created
and they're all preventable kaylee every
one of them thank you i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis